so leapfrog is the world's first fund
focused on micro Insurance and Financial
Inclusion for the poor it is a
for-profit private equity fund but we
believe that this is a tremendous asset
class that is able to generate strong
returns for investors while also lifting
millions of people out of poverty and
why is that well there are some
incredibly exciting insurance businesses
out there and those businesses have
often been serving the middle class but
the middle class has some has become
saturated or it's not the most exciting
opportunity low income people Express a
very strong demand for micro insurance
so several of my partner's did a study
that is a hundred country landscape
study of micro insurance in the world's
100 poorest countries and it shows that
there are a billion people out there who
are willing and able to pay for micro
insurance you have a market of a billion
people and it is 3% penetrators now the
opportunity there and the demand is
intensive because people lie awake at
night worrying they're going to lose
everything
the demand for microcredit may be strong
as people want to be entrepreneurs or
have consumption needs but almost
everybody lies awake at night if you're
worrying you're going to lose everything
so there are a billion people waiting to
consume this product and insurers have
just been slow to recognize this
opportunity and act on it now what we as
leapfrog do is invest in exciting
businesses in Africa and Asia that serve
low-income and poor people with micro
insurance that meet this incredibly
intensive demand and they're very
exciting and innovative businesses and
we provide them with the capital and the
expertise because several of my partners
are some of the world's leading
authorities on micro insurance
distribution on product design and
pricing on all these different areas and
the expertise to help them grow
dramatically now the exciting thing
about
it doesn't just apply to poor people
also applies to people who are excluded
for other reasons people who have
disabilities people who have hiv/aids or
diabetes that are severe and can't get
insurance now when someone can't get
insurance they often can't get a home
loan they often can't get entry to the
economy they often struggle to get the
the medications they need so this
intervention helping poor low-income and
financially excluded people to get
insurance is both hugely important and
it can be very profitable and what
leapfrog does is it puts these two
things together it is a profit with
purpose firm and I believe it represents
the next frontier for for investment in
the sense that you can generate both
social and financial returns you don't
have to choose as a person between
having money and having meaning and I
think all of us field we would like to
bring those two things together why
should you have to have these terrible
trade-offs between the two and you can
and get engage in a business that has
non market racking returns because this
is a very different asset class from all
the others out there in turn including
alternative asset classes and at the
same time feel that you're helping
millions of people to get out of poverty
and that's why we're so passionate about
leapfrog and why President Clinton and
the Wall Street Journal and other great
organizations have got behind us and are
supporting us it really is a group
effort we we need it's it's because it
is so innovative we need the support of
many many different people
micro-insurance products can sometimes
be less than $1 a year and sometimes can
be 10 or $15 a month it really just
depends on the country the income level
and the nature of the product so for
instance in South Africa for four to
seven dollars you can get a life
insurance product where if the person or
their spouse or their child dies there's
a payout of say around seven hundred and
fifty dollars and now that is a lot of
money for a poor person who would
otherwise might be left destitute
so we yes we're interested in life
insurance above all because we think
it's hugely important and because it can
be done very profitably health insurance
which is much harder because you have to
have a health infrastructure that can
can deal with it and there's all sorts
of moral hazards but it is the most
demanded insurance and it's something we
really want to support there is there
are all sorts of other kinds of
insurance accidental death and
disability insurance there is even low
income housing insurance and crop
insurance and other kinds of index based
insurance so we we think that the
majority of our investments will be in
life insurance but we think that and
we're excited about several health
insurance opportunities but we think
there is room there for investments
across these areas and we actually
unlike many other firm we actually hope
that there are a thousand leapfrogs that
bloom to mix the metaphors because we
think it is such a huge market that many
many players can come into the sector
and do this profitably collaborate
together and we're already seeing large
firms like aliens like Zurich like AIG
entering the micro insurance space in a
more significant way and seeing the
opportunity here and seeing their
policyholder bases grow dramatically in
numbers well beyond their middle-class
customer growth and so I I think what
we're on the cusp of is the burgeoning
of a whole new era in which micro
insurance is going to be brought to low
income people globally and leapfrog
hopes to lead that charge